wings over has been around for almost 20
years
and it was our favorite restaurant when
we were in school so we actually started
off as franchisees
my three business partners and i started
that restaurant while doing full-time
jobs and running other companies
and so in that process we realized that
we wanted to grow the brand and do a lot
more than what was being done at the
time
so we ended up acquiring the brand a
little bit over three years ago and
since then
totally reimagined what wings over was
and so we'll
quickly be at over 40 locations and so
the food's amazing
a lot of people are scared to sometimes
do what they love because
it may become work but for me it was
truly something that i loved and so
as we got involved with the business we
saw there was so much more potential
whenever i would wear a wings over shirt
in boston
or in milwaukee or madison people would
say wait
wing's over i used to have that in
college i loved that place
and so seeing that type of nostalgia we
knew that there was
a lot that we could do to make the brand
even better than what it was
make it consistent and really grow it to
where it could be
when i look at people that look like me
that work harder than i do and the
challenges that they face
it's very tough to say that the american
dream exists
i talked to my parents about this and i
talked to a lot of different people
but the american dream hasn't been mine
it started with my grandparents it
started with my parents
when they came to the us from mexico
with the
belief that if they worked hard enough
they would be able to create a better
future for their family
and it's because of their incredible
sacrifices the sacrifices of my business
partners
sacrifices of so many strangers that
have come before me
that i am where i am today i share my
story so that people can hopefully
relate and say
wow i'm a person of color i'm a first
generation student uh
we didn't grow up with much so that they
know that
there are people like them that can do
it
part of my story is part of what makes
me who i am and
i wouldn't trade it
you